Speaker 1: Why don't we go next?
Where to even go?
Let's go to Roy from South Jersey.
Roy, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Good afternoon.
Speaker 1: Welcome.
What's on your mind?
Speaker 2: I just wanted to say that the Alex
Jones conspiracy about Vlad the Impaler and
all that stuff.
Yeah.
From a historical standpoint, it doesn't make
any sense.
Right.
That house that he was talking about wasn't
founded for another 400 years.
Vlad the Impaler was not the progenitor of
all European dynasties, etc..
So from a historical standpoint, it makes
no sense.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I got an email about that.
Let me see if I can even find it.
It was pretty funny from someone who said,
oh wait.
Oh, it was from you.
Just you emailed in.
Yeah.
You had a bunch of interesting things where
you explained that like the head, the family
he's saying is the oldest family isn't, and
he's got the lineages wrong.
And the funny thing is, like any normal person
would listen to that and know it doesn't make
any sense.
But then as you did, when you actually look
into the specifics, it makes even less sense.
Speaker 2: Right.
Now, I wanted to ask you a question.
I've been called a monster for this.
I shower with my glasses on.
Am I a monster for that?
Speaker 1: That I have never heard of that
ever.
I've never heard of anyone doing that.
I will sometimes shower with my contact on
and I know that that's controversial.
And people will say, Oh, sir, you could get
a crazy infection from that.
I mean, I've been doing it off and on for,
you know, 20 years, but I have never heard
of anyone showering with glasses on.
How don't they get all steamed up?
Speaker 2: Well, yeah, but then I'll just,
you know, wipe them off with my towel and
then I'll be fine.
Speaker 1: Wait, you're bringing a towel into
the shower?
Speaker 2: Well, it'll be hanging out outside
of it.
And then I can just, you know, poke my head
out and wash them off for a second.
Speaker 1: So how many times do you have to
do that during your typical shower?
Speaker 2: Oh, like four or five.
Speaker 1: So you're telling me that what
you do is you wear glasses during the shower,
hang a towel outside, and then five times
per shower, lean out to wipe them.
Speaker 2: That's correct.
Speaker 1: Wouldn't it be easier just to take
them off?
Speaker 2: Um.
Probably, yeah.
Do it all my life, you know.
Speaker 1: What, are you, nearsighted?
Speaker 2: I'm far sighted.
Speaker 1: Oh, so these are reading glasses?
Yes.
Oh, interesting.
And you need you feel like you need those
to shower.
Speaker 2: I mean, I don't want to like slip
on something or fall or whatever, so I kind
of like feel more comfortable with them on.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, safety is our number
one priority, if that's what you need to feel
safe.
But it is certainly unorthodox.
I will I will leave it there, Roy.
Speaker 2: All right.
Thank you for your assessment.
Speaker 1: You're still allowed in the audience,
though.
It's not that crazy.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
All right.
Roy from South Jersey.
Wow.
Showering with glasses on.
I've never heard of it.
Never.
Never heard of it.
Very interesting.
Let's go next to now.
I'm going to get this right this time.
Let's go to Elias from Texas.
Did I get it right this time?
Speaker 2: Peace initiative, Mujahideen.
Speaker 1: So what's going on?
This group.
Speaker 2: Okay.
It seems like in the U.S., the folks that
are concerned about climate change are in
the minority when it comes to affecting public
policy.
How can we overcome the overwhelming political
odds to pass meaningful legislation?
And how can we how can we do a quick, quick
enough to hopefully avoid the worst effects
of climate change that are predicted?
Speaker 1: I don't know that I agree with
the premise.
Now, let's let's see if we can clarify it.
You're saying most of the general public doesn't
want to do anything about climate change or
are most of our elected officials don't?
Speaker 2: I think I think elected officials
is like all the money that comes from oil
companies and all of that.
Speaker 1: So here's the thing.
Most of the top of the population does want
to do something about climate change.
So the solution is we need that.
This is a crazy radical idea.
We need to elect people who will do the will
of the voters.
And I know it's like so quaint.
The problem, of course, is between gerrymandering
and campaign finance and super PACs and all
of these other voter suppression techniques
and all of it, we are not actually getting
elected officials that represent the will
of the people.
Think about abortion rights.
The will of the people is overwhelmingly that
abortion be legal in most cases.
If you look at the Senate, that's not the
view in the Senate of the 100 senators.
So we've got a real problem there.
We don't really have representation.
Speaker 2: Right.
Is it okay if I follow up with another question,
please?
Speaker 1: Yes, go ahead.
Speaker 2: How do you feel about bringing
a child into this world, knowing that you're
going to be serving them with the burden of
living on on an inhabitable planet?
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So here's the deal with that for me.
I believe that only people are going to solve
the problems that we have, and I believe they
are solvable.
And so I know a lot of people have taken this
approach of I would never have a kid because
the country, the countries screwed the planet,
screwed the species or whatever.
I think that if we don't bring some people
in who maybe could be problem solvers, we
have no shot.
You miss 100% of the shots you don't take.
Yeah.
And so I want to have a shot at it.
And so I want to bring someone in who maybe
could be someone that find solutions.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Well, thank you so much, David.
Speaker 1: All right.
Speaker 2: Thank you for saying my my name.
My name correctly, too.
Speaker 1: But that's my pleasure.
Thank you for the call.
All right.
Very good.
There is Alias.